hey everyone this is sarah with  registernursern.com and in this video  i'm going to demonstrate how to assess  the babinski reflex in  a newborn this is seen when the bottom  of the foot is stroked from the heel  upward along the outward part of the  foot so what's going to happen  with this you will see the big toe  dorsiflex  so it's going to bend backwards and the  other toes are going to fan  out or spread out and this is what you  want to see  in an infant now in an adult you do not  want to see this response i actually  have a video  where i show you what a normal and  abnormal babinski reflex is in an adult  and you can check that video out if  you're interested and this tends to  disappear this type of response around  about one year of  age okay so that wraps up this video on  how to assess the babinski reflex in a  newborn and also be sure to check out  the other reflex videos in this series